آسف ولكن إليك سؤال آخر
حول المتغير أه وهذا السؤال
الذي تم اكتشافه في جنوب إفريقيا
لأنه يبدو أنه يحتوي على
طفرات إضافية يقول العلماء إنها تتضمن
تعديلات أكثر شمولاً لجزء رئيسي
من الفيروس
يعرف باسم بروتين سبايك الذي
يستخدمه الفيروس  لإصابة الخلايا
البشرية وقد يجعل الفيروس أقل عرضة
للاستجابة المناعية
التي تسببها اللقاحات التي يعمل صانعو الأدوية لديك
الآن لمعرفة مدى فعالية
اللقاحات ضد المتغيرات الجديدة
ولكن أعني هل هناك شك في
أن لديك  الاشتباه في أن السرية 19
يمكن أن تكون في نهاية المطاف
مثل الأنفلونزا الموسمية التي تحتاجها للحصول على
تحصين سنوي
جيدًا ، إنه فيروسات rna
وهي تتحول وتتحول
بسرعة إلى حد ما ولكن هذا الفيروس لا يتحول
بسرعة كما يقول الإنفلونزا ،
فهناك إنزيم تصحيح لغوي في
حالة النسخ المتماثل التي تتيح لها أن تكون
أكثر أو أقل عرضة للخطأ أثناء مرورها ،
لذا فسنضطر إلى تحديث اللقاح من
حين لآخر.
لا أعتقد ذلك ، لذا فأنت
تعلم أنه قد يكون كل عامين أو ثلاثة أعوام ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي عندما ننظر إليه
خاصةً المتغير الذي
نراه في المملكة المتحدة ، فإن
البديل 501 هو ما يعادل
مثل بروتين سبايك  موقع يسمى
مجال ربط المستقبلات
الذي يشبه يدي وفي الوقت الحالي
تغير الإبهام فقط ،
لذا فإن الحماية التي أمتلكها ضد
أصابعي الأخرى لا تزال موجودة وستظل
موجودة مع اللقاح القديم إنه فقط
الإبهام  تغيرت
عندما تحدث المزيد من التغييرات بحيث
تبدو يدي مختلفة
أكثر مما نحتاج إلى التحديث ، لذا في الوقت
الحالي يبدو اللقاح رائعًا
، يبدو أنه
سيحمينا بالتأكيد من البديل البريطاني ،
حيث سيختبرون البديل الجنوب
أفريقي للتأكد
ولكن  مرة أخرى طالما أن التغييرات ليست
كثيرة جدًا ، يجب أن يكون هناك
تشابه كافٍ بينهما في المواقع المهمة
ليؤدي إلى تحييد
وتقليل شدة المرض